my turn yeah you're being targeted by
vats what is your weak spot [ __ ] there's
the penis for me 1% chance to hit target
to smoke myself this is versus the
GameSpot show that pits your favorite
games consoles franchises and hot-button
issues against each other this week
fallout this beloved franchise has many
games worth fighting for but in this
video it's going to be the Battle of the
studios with Bethesda's fallout 3 vs.
obsidians Fallout New Vegas this also
marks a special episode as we filmed in
the GameSpot u.s. office making this a
battle of Nations arguing the case for
Fallout 3 is handsome American boy Mike
McCarty and fighting for Fallout New
Vegas is the slightly less handsome
British boy Dave Jewett each are going
to argue the corner for their game over
the course of three randomly picked
topics with the overall winner being
decided by you the wonderful viewers
last episode's fight between pokemon
then and pokemon now saw oscar handily
win with 63% of the vote you really
can't beat the originals anyways to vote
for who you think argue their case
better on this episode we're gonna be
throwing up a clickable poll right here
on YouTube okay then let's get to the
debate
okay so I'll Fallout New Vegas versus
fallout 3 first one is narrative you
won't start want me to start I'll start
I kind of already touched on it I think
at an open-world game it's kind of the
antithesis of an open-world story to be
able to have it branch and three
different is at three different
directions three still mainly to 3 and
new Vegas not the note 4 and 4 ok I
think by doing that they kind of limit
it to your experience of the world I
think the main quest isn't the actual
draw of fallout 3 but I think the fact
that you can do all of it in one
playthrough obviously can get at
different endings as the lone wanderer
than the movies I think that allows you
there's no like FOMO that you're gonna
be missing this branching part narrative
or this ending for like full-on new
Vegas the beauty of it is because the
three storylines three main quest lines
are so different and even the starring
of Fallout New Vegas is much more
enjoyable for me it's you're the courier
maybe it allows you to project more of
like a roleplay element to it and that's
another thing that Fallout New Vegas
does really well it focuses more on on
roleplay you can take on these different
roles if there's more morale choice
there's more feedback for making morale
choice in Fallout 3 like yeah sure you
can blow up Megaton and people don't
like you anymore but in Fallout New
Vegas you can make friends the Boomers
the powder gangers might hate you
Goodsprings might worship you the people
in the Vegas trip might not want to hang
out and all these will change the way
you play the game and that's not even
talking about the the wider for you know
main questline see the NCR that's like
the you know that's always the good guys
caesar's legion those two straight away
a hugely different you have like a
modern sort of rebuilt government and
then slaving kaiser miss the house you
can find like the disembodied head of a
living piece of jerky and team of that
guy or you can go it complete your own
and lean into that role adamant be like
no I don't want any of these I want to
create an independent Vegas in an
independent way you know exactly the way
I want to I still felt as if in an
open-world game I haven't worked a
connection to it when I'm actually just
I can explore it and then see the entire
story in one playthrough
and then it's just like kind of out
finding my own story the story in
fallout 3 restricts you because you wake
up your door you're pulling in a vault
you know who your that is you're in that
vault until you're 16 you are a vault
dweller but in in New Vegas you're a
courier that's its origins restricted
way you're saying yeah in New Vegas
because because you're the couriered not
a vault whether you've existed in this
world for a while and it means that you
can create your own backstory you could
have been abandoned Wondra you can stick
with a courier thing you can play as as
anything topic to world the world in new
vegas fallout 3 well the the maps so the
map is in new vegas is a little bigger
but it's also full of much more stuff
there's much more to see there's much
more to do to the density and like
entrapment and claustrophobia fallout 3
was one of the things that I didn't like
about their game whereas New Vegas
everything feels so varied and different
everything has its own character but
beyond that you have more things that
you haven't seen that like the NCR I
find really interesting because on the
surface it's like yeah that the soldiers
but you haven't seen in Fallout of
government a government that's taken
over a government that has like like
power and a crating infrastructure
that's that's not really been chemically
their malevolent cover like a bunch of
bad old racists but they're trying to be
a government you've seen a government it
might be a better government than what
you see in fallout 3 but it's still
government but alright so world I'll
talk about world I wanna talk about how
what the games are about cuz I think
that's functional that's like integral
to the how the world works Oh fallout 3
is about like the failures of government
in general and diplomacy and then
obviously you've got these monuments to
American government left and right it's
a photograph of a time in America
obviously an aesthetic of these games is
like you know like the they were still
very much in like the tech and culture
of the 1950's and etc but I feel as if
fallout 3 works in a different way and
to me and much more impactful way it's
more about being a voyeur and this
post-apocalyptic world to me
post-apocalyptic games and movies and
fiction is being a voyeur and seeing
this like frozen moment in time I like
seeing the effects like the immediate
effects of the war but although the
arguments that you you've just said that
was lost for a lot part because the game
was just claustrophobic a gray it was
tough to find all these wonderful
tidbits because it was so closing in and
because it was just such a and you come
out for Alan do you think that's
claustrophobic when you come out of all
you see all the areas and you know in
this in the ends of DC with all the
rubble is a bigger world you don't get
to DC you don't have to go to did you
see you're acting like everybody and if
it doesn't game goes straight for the
main questline
you could just go all the way up north
and fall out and be completely avoiding
over DC there's nothing saying you can't
and it's great because of that world
lets you do that yeah Vegas does the
same thing but I find that that new
Vegas has more in it you've got you've
got things that are started it's like
the white glove society you have like
the vaults that are overgrown and like
this the sacrifice is in there there's
there's just more to Fallout New Vegas
third and less topic quests I still err
on the side of Fallout 3 but you've had
you've got some ammunition I will give
you that I want to talk about you know
you've got the the superhuman gambit
when everybody remembers the antagonize
ER the mechanist you come across it's
this feud that you're mediating between
two like people who have come up in a
post-apocalyptic wasteland and said oh I
want to be a superhero
they're like cosplayers that like are
the only blessed two inhabitants in this
town and it's hilarious you kind of hear
the motivations in the backstory these
two people and how they've come to just
like they've been there how many years
just Pickering they don't want to settle
anything that's just their life like
they're trying to find meaning in their
lives afterward it becomes this like
existential thing where you know the
antagonize er has his own view of the
world or at the world that exists you
have a mechanism as it's his view of the
world you come across it you're kind of
mediating it or you could screw it up
and one will attack you and you'll kill
him
but I want talk about my favorite side
quest as well in Fallout 3 it's the
replicated man when you come across
rivet city this amazing city that people
have built on this aircraft carrier a
replicated man is when you first start
maybe not first star but it's when you
first like really get into learning
about replicant you have to start fine
hunting down this replicant it results
in you getting the best weapon in the
game my appending a321 plasma rifle but
in order to find them and you have to go
through and learn about the replicant
and how they've become like this
secondary class to humans you have to
learn about the backstory that led to
that you have to essentially become
Blade Runner and fallout 3 and that
itself was amazing and the writing there
the characters you meet it in rivet city
and then the characters you meet when
you go back into the metro area
fantastic
see for me I I like the gradient of the
quests in New Vegas you have serious
quests and then you have like really
goofy quests things like like serious
ones when you find boons wife's murderer
and and lead her lead
spoilers lead her outside at night and
bring ya sniper sit in the giant
dinosaur shootin like his wife's murder
that's sick and that that was totally
quite dark because she had motivations
to commit this horrid events and then
you got one like the best companions of
the game but then you have like a super
eclectic stuff where you can send ghouls
to the moon you help like it was that's
quite a long quest and you spend all
this time figuring out how to send these
ghouls you believe there's a there's a
life in space on this rocket ship and
sending them just to the skies I think
New Vegas has some of the most
interesting vaults there's one vault in
the strip it's very interesting because
it's been turned into a motel because
mr. house won it playing blackjack but
that's like something a volt has always
been very kind of an intense element to
the Fallout game so it's this one's
clean in turn a motel I know you're a
fan of vault 11 I think because New
Vegas has leaned into the eclectic stuff
the writing that's gone into the vaults
has produced some of the most
interesting vote stuff feel like all the
side quests are more cohesive in Fallout
3 New Vegas has great quest but I feel
like they're more standalone short
stories within a bigger story
I like that though I guess because you
made the point that you feel like
fallout 3 you're having more impact in
the world I really like that in New
Vegas you're having very intimate impact
on the characters and I think that's
where we're gonna have to wrap things up
but who do you think
the overall debate let us know by voting
in our poll on the top right corner of
the video or if you're over on
gamespot.com
by putting your thoughts in the comment
section below remember it'll be your
votes that decide who wins so make
yourselves heard all right then now it's
time for this week's quickfire round
series of dumb fun questions written by
the rest of the team do an impression of
your favorite character
everybody just sounds like a 15 I was
gonna do fist though that I just know
that it's ready to serve
you're being targeted by vats what is
your weak spot the penis for me what
cassette chance to hit talk to small I
set myself up for that one I have a big
head Oh what's your most likely to hit
spot or critical spot my most likely to
hit is probably my biceps I'll have to
snow you're kidding I have a large head
I think as well it's shaped like an
anvil my weak spots I'm still going with
my D was your personal nuclear
apocalypse strategy I have a zombie
wombat I don't think I've ever thought
about me so I kind of just accepted a
nuclear yeah I'm screwed
my uncle has a bunker in the woods in
the already so he's got a doomsday
prepper yeah I could call him up hey Bob
I'm in San Francisco right now you know
that dungeon that you have that I used I
used to vacation and there's a kid would
come in handy I think I'm all set he's
got like canned food water
iodized or whatever they're called salt
say lanai sir you'd be fine in America
it's like if mutants Roseau guns
everywhere well let's not bring up that
that's just fuel for the Second
Amendment people in London knows what
we're gonna do friend uncle Google the
cricket bat well that's what they do and
vom you just shoot them what are your
special stats in real life what's your
what your like highest form strength six
perception by oh you're gonna be the
numbers okay endurance seven charisma
intelligence I'll give myself an eight
forget it's a five
look I'm just gonna say my highest one
would be walking always saw myself very
lucky I think my next one would be
agility yeah I'm like I'm cool you
should have seen me oh this is your turn
should have seen me playing lacrosse in
high school I wasn't good I just fully
school down here everyone would you
rather be killed by 10,000 red roaches
or one giant record what about me killed
one giant I think I feel like you get
stabbed once by a pincer as opposed to
like this is devoured remember to get
your voice heard in our poll or in the
comment section below and tell us who
you think argue their case better and if
you enjoyed this episode of vs. make
sure to hit that subscribe button as
we'll have new episodes every Wednesday
thanks for watching see ya
[Music]
you